how much time did the two of you spend
in acting classes some actors don't take
acting classes some I don't like
currently yeah I mean I I studied in
college and and then when I moved to LA
I was in a couple of different like
schools I guess under different teachers
I don't know for how long maybe like a
year and a half but I I mean I do
coaching like private one-on-ones when I
have something that I'm about to go
audition for or if I just if I'm like
getting in a rut if I'm doing something
if I can feel myself sort of making the
same choices all the time I'll go and
just work with somebody to to get
somebody else's eyes and ears into the
situation and they can kind of call you
out of it but other than that I mean the
the class like scenario for me just
became a bit redundant I think after you
you know there's different schools
that's like thought and and there's
different ways to approach everything
but eventually you're just melding those
all into whatever works for you anyhow
and so I think if you hear too much of
it it just it becomes a little redundant
and so yeah I feel like I took what I
needed to from and you're always
learning but I feel like I feel like
real life application is can be like the
most of educational in that regard yeah
I definitely have floated in and out of
it and I'm about to get back into like a
scene study this to me it just I love
watching other people and listening to
other people's processes even though it
there's nothing I would ever do maybe or
maybe completely something I would do
just getting into the heads of other
people and where they go and how they
come up with things to me is really
interesting and I mean I think the
growth aspect of this is you know it
doesn't stop and there's a constant need
for it
and it's almost like you know when time
permits I fly back into that you know
and stay there for a minute just to get
some juice from another you know from
another tree so to speak refresh button
you